MATIAS DUARTE: Get the
welcome slide.
There we go.
All right.
Welcome, everybody.
Hi.
My name's Matias Duarte.
I run the design team
here at Android.
And I am super, super excited to
welcome you all here today.
This is the first Google I/O
where we can have an entire
day of Android design
sessions.
We're gonna have an entire
day of design sessions
here in this room.
[APPLAUSE]
MATIAS DUARTE: That's crazy.
Is this really Google I/O?
Google I/O with a day
of design sessions?
Yeah.
No, that's really awesome.
So obviously you're here because
you care about design.
Whether you're big team with
an established track record
and lots of published apps or
just a one man shop who's just
getting started,
design matters.
Design is going to make your
app, take it from great to
insanely great.
In January we launched the
Android Design Guide.
It's a bunch of tools to
help you make your
app beautifully designed.
I like to think of it as kind of
like an open source library
for design.
It's a bunch of patterns and
solutions that you don't have
to think about.
You don't have to reinvent
the wheel.
If you're not sure how to make
it easy for users to navigate
between screens, that's OK.
We got a solution for you.
You don't have to spend
time testing or
experimenting with that.
If you're not sure how to
make something legible
or clear, it's OK.
We've got a solution for you.
You don't have to figure out the
basic metrics or grids or
contrasts or colors.
But there's a lot more
to design than just
what's in the guide.
And that's what today's sessions
are all about.
This morning we start with
Design for Success, which is
an awesome overview of the
entire design process.
How to slot the design
guide into the
entire development process.
And we're going to show
you some examples
of how to do that.
Next, we have So You've Read the
Design Guide, Now What?,
which is a very practical
session which is going to show
you how to take all the
principles that you learned in
Design Guide and turn
them into perfect
pixels on your screen.
One of my favorite sessions and
the one I'm most excited
about is Navigation.
Because navigation is the
essential backbone of any
well-designed experience.
It's what makes everything
make sense.
It's what gives people
a sense of place
and keeps them grounded.
So I hope I'll see you there.
And then finally we have a
two-hour workshop, which I
forget what we called it.
Playing with Patterns.
Playing with Patterns is also a
really exciting because here
you're going to see other
developers who've actually
taken the style guide and used
it, used it to leverage their
design and expand
their design.
Design Guide is not
a constraint.
It's not a shackle.
It's a tool.
It's an accelerator.
It's a way to boost your
experience even further.
And these guys have done it and
they're going to show you
how they did it and hopefully
give you some
good tips on that.
I hope you'll attend
all of them.
Even if you can't, the day's
not over then because after
the day of design sessions, the
design team will be at the
W Hotel bar later in
the afternoon.
And if you have any questions
or you just want to hang out
with the design team and have
some design pixie dust rub off
on you, I hope you guys will
come by and make friends.
So with that, I would like to
introduce Jens Nagel, Rachel
Garb, and Nate Streu from the
design team who are going to
teach you all about Design
for Success.
So give them a round of
applause, please.
[APPLAUSE]
JENS NAGEL: Thanks, Matias.
So let's get started.
Where does it all begin?
It usually begins
with an idea.
So you have an idea
for an app.
The thing is that,
coincidentally, thousands of
other app developers
have one too.
And some of those ideas
might actually be
pretty close to yours.
So it's really time to
differentiate yourself.
And we want to help you
do it through design.
One important way, as I said,
to differentiate yourself is
through design.
And organizations
realize that.
And they usual verbalize
it as look and feel.
So look is an easy enough to
grasp concept as it speaks to
the visual properties
of an app.
But feel is a little bit more
nebulous and less clearly
articulated.
To clear this up, where the feel
is, and what goes into a
design team we want to look at
the basic functions of a
design team.
For example, our team-- the
Android User Experience Team.
And, yes.
That is our logo.
Nice.
So first up in the run down of
subteams in our team is user
experience research.
So UX research shapes sort
of the product and design
direction by bringing
in insights about
users to the team.
I'll introduce them in a little
bit more detail in a
bit, so let's go to
the next one.
NATE STREU: All right.
So visual design.
This is next up.
And this can go by a lot
of different names.
And you can call it
what you will.
It's imperative to the
success of your app.
Visual design can span a wide
breadth of disciplines from
typography, iconography,
animation, art direction, and
design production.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
So next up, interaction
design.
Interaction designers
define the structure
and behavior of apps.
So we organize functionality
in the screens.
We map out how the users will
navigate between the screens.
And then we identify all of the
information and actions
that need to appear
on each screen.
Now although we do more line
drawings then pixel perfect
mocks, our work is highly
detail-oriented.
And just like programmers, we
need to make sure that every
use case or condition
is accounted for.
JENS NAGEL: Next up is a
really exciting team.
It's the prototyping team.
And they make complex new
interaction ideas tangible.
So they create functional
prototypes that allow us to
experience a novel design
firsthand and evaluate it.
RACHEL GARB: And this is our
technical writer, Shawn.
He plays a dual role
on our team.
First, he creates help
for Android.
This can take a variety of forms
like printed materials,
web-based help centers, and help
that you see in the app.
Second, he shapes the
voice of Android.
And he does this with his
responsibility for our UI
writing guidelines and working
across the teams to make sure
that terminology is used
consistently in our apps and
our system.
JENS NAGEL: And then last but
not least is what I would like
to call the glue.
So these are the people that
work across functions.
And Matias is one of them.
He's the one that provides
design direction to the team.
But then we also have
project management.
And generally people that are
there to make the design
machine run.
So that is a fairly big
team as far as design
teams go, on average.
I guess.
Maybe not for the scale of
Android, but in your
organization you have access
to a crack design team all
dressed in black like the
guys on the left.
That's great.
Let them do their thing.
But you might be in the
situation where you're on a
smaller team.
Or maybe your even this app
army of one, one person
playing multiple different
instruments.
Even in that situation where
you have your hands people
with all sorts of things,
designers is always doable.
And today we want to show
you how you can do that.
So where should you start
with the design process?
A clue can actually come here
from motivational psychology,
of all things.
Some of you might be familiar
with Maslow's
Hierarchy of Needs.
Basically postulates that all
human behavior is geared
towards sort of fulfilling basic
needs first before you
progress to the higher levels,
the higher needs.
So for example, before I take
care of the safety of my
employment, I probably want to
breathe, eat, and sleep.
So these so the more
basic needs here.
So you might ask now,
what does that have
to do with app design?
And that's a good question.
But it is the principle
of how you should
approach app design.
App designers really should
address their apps' design
needs by progressing through a
similar Hierarchy of Needs.
The contents here, of course,
are a little bit different.
So you should address the
design foundations first
before striving to address
higher level needs.
In this pyramid, if you just
cover the first three levels
of the pyramid, you already have
a really competitive app
that measures up against
the competition well.
And it will be also an app that
is sort of a good citizen
on the Android platform in that
it sort of follows the
rules and regulations
of the UI.
The Android Design Guide, which
you hear about more in a
second, sort of gets you
to that third level.
It mainly deals with the second
and the third tier of
this pyramid.
So as a takeaway, make sure
that you cover your bases.
So before you do this--
and that might an instinct.
Everybody wants the pretty app
that does exciting things like
nice transitions
and everything.
But before you do this, really
make sure that you do that.
The base of the pyramid.
Because if you don't do that,
that often equals the
proverbial lipstick on a pig.
So to give you a little bit more
context about the Design
Guide, Rachel will give
you whirlwind tour.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
Thanks.
So--
whoops.
Show of hands.
How many of you have
visited this site?
JENS NAGEL: Wow.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
And that looks like at least
3/4 of the room.
Terrific.
JENS NAGEL: Awesome.
RACHEL GARB: So for those who
haven't yet seen this, this is
the Android Design Guide.
And we launched it earlier
this year.
And we're updating
it regularly.
It's for anyone who needs
to make design
decisions, big and small.
Whether you're a professional
designer or you wouldn't be
caught dead wearing all black.
If you're designing an
Android app, you
should go check it out.
Now I'm not going to give you
a full tour, because that
would take way too much time.
But I want to point out a few
pages that I think you'll find
particularly helpful.
So the first is application
structure.
Which Jens has up.
A lot of what we're talking
about today
is introduced here.
And you can think of it as sort
of a one-page Cliff's
Notes to designing
Android apps.
It provides overview of things
like hierarchical, structure,
navigation, layout, identity.
It's a quick and easy read.
The next thing I want to show
you is the action bar.
Please read this and
refer to it often.
The action bar is the most
important structural element
of your app.
Why is that?
Because in a very compact space,
it does a lot of heavy
lifting for you.
It's where you can present
actions, whether they're
primary, like these, or whether
they are not so
important and can go in
an overflow menu.
It's where you give your
app an identity.
And if your app has hierarchical
structure,
there's a way built in to
navigate up to the top.
If you want to provide different
views on the
information without the user
leaving the screen, you have a
way that they can switch
the views.
Now the action bar pattern isn't
just important because
of all it does.
It's also important because
this will help your users
learn your app more quickly.
This has become a familiar and
expected pattern in Android
and all of the Android's
core apps use it.
The next section I
want to point you
to is building blocks.
This is where you'll find all
of the information about the
elements that you'll use to
create apps like list, menus,
buttons, tabs, and so on.
You can see there's a lot of
illustrations and examples.
And this covers both interaction
and visual design.
And finally, design patterns.
Which you'll find under
get started.
But we're not going to read
through it right now.
I think this is best
read on your own.
But I would like to take a
moment to give you a little
background on the design
principles.
So if you could switch
to the slide.
And--
there.
So if your users could talk,
here are some of the things
that they'd be saying.
Now how do we know this?
We did extensive
user research.
We went out and observed
and talked with a
lot of Android owners.
We saw some clear trends and
themes, both things they loved
and things they didn't
like so much.
And for Ice Cream Sandwich we
wanted to do more of the
lovable stuff.
And, of course, we wanted to
stop doing the things that
users found annoying,
frustrating, and simply unlovable.
So we took our user insights and
we transformed them into
short, memorable catch phrases
that our team could work with
and share with our teams and
use on day-to-day basis.
We made sure that they were
phrased in actionable ways.
And we found that they've been
really helpful, both at the
start of a project when we're
just figuring out broad
directions to take, as well as
when we're in the thick of it
working on granular design
details and prioritizing bugs.
So we invite you to
use them too.
They're very general, and they
apply to any and all apps.
Now I'm going to turn
it back to the Jens.
JENS NAGEL: Thank you, Rachel.
So today we want to give you an
applied overview of sort of
how you can find your way up the
design pyramid and build
an app that does what your users
need it to do that is
structurally sound and
also adheres to the
Android Design Guide.
Our example app for today is
the Google I/O app that you
hopefully all had a chance to
download onto your shiny new
Nexus 7 tablets.
If you don't have it or if you
follow along from home, you
can actually download it
from the Play Store.
And so that the code for this
will also be open sourced the
week after the conference.
So if you're a developer and you
want to take a closer peek
at how it was built,
you can do that.
Full disclosure.
Today is a little bit of a
smoke and mirrors session
because we actually didn't
design this app.
It was Roman Nurik.
You want to stand up?
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
JENS NAGEL: Some of you might
know him through his work at
Android Developer Relations.
But we picked it for this
session because, yeah, a, it's
a great app.
b, it uses mostly framework
elements.
So all stuff that you
will find in the
Android Design Guide.
And it's a good example of
what you can achieve by
applying the style guide and
getting your app to that third
level that we've been
talking about.
Because we're really not
playing much in the app
Nirvana in the top of the
pyramid with this app.
So let's get started at the
bottom floor of our pyramid
with utility and purpose.
So as you begin your design
project, it pays off to heed
the advice of the mad man.
And that is, "of each thing,
ask; what is it in, and of
itself." So the fundamental
question, what is your app in
and of itself?
So what is the purpose
of your app?
What are the technical goals
that serve that purpose?
And what are the things
that are most
important to your users?
So why should we think
about purpose?
Because app design, just like
building design, is or should
be purpose-driven.
The purpose of the building,
for example, has a profound
impact on how it is built.
Let's look at an example of a
purpose-built building, like
an airport for example.
Think about an airport from the
travelers' point of view.
The mere fact that it is an
airport already sort of shapes
expectations of what places are
there, what the functional
elements, what processes
are in that building.
So if I say airport,
you can probably
conjure up a lot of things.
And if we all wrote them down
in the room, they would
probably match a lot.
You would see a lot of check
in, dropping off bags.
So the process, for example, of
getting onto an airplane is
very similar everywhere.
So you arrive.
Then you drop off
your luggage.
You go through security.
Maybe before you leave
you want to grab a
bite to eat or drink.
And then finally, you get to
the gate and get on the
aircraft and leave.
So regardless of the
architectural style,
regardless of what the airport
looks like, airports are
really geared towards
that common purpose.
And by doing that, they're very
consistent places and
users really expect them
to be just that.
Apps, in a sense, are no
different in that the purpose
of an app also establishes
expectations of functional
places such as a screen with
information on it.
That's sort of a functional
place akin the
check in at an airport.
Then there are also actions
associated with those
functional places, such
as here, actions
on an action bar.
And there's also navigation,
of course, between those
functional places.
So they are very similar,
really, to how a building is
constructed due to a purpose.
So back to our I/O app.
Now that we know that the
purpose of app really drives
its design, let's get started by
formulating the high level
mission statement.
And that could be our first high
level mission statement
here, conference guide that aids
people while planning,
exploring, and attending
Google I/O.
This is sort of your
elevator speech.
So if you have an
app, you should
have an elevator speech.
You should be able to sort of
communicate with just a
sentence what your
app is about.
And that is probably then pretty
close to its purpose.
So now that we have that, we
now need to establish the
technical goals that
serve the purpose.
And also a sense of the
functional places, actions,
and navigations for our app.
So to do that, we need to
collect information obviously,
because we might not just be
subject matter experts about
the app that we're building.
So we essentially need
to become just that--
subject matter experts at
what people's needs
at conferences are.
So we need to ask questions
just like these.
What do people do before,
during, and after a
conference?
What tools do they use?
Maybe we know some
of them, maybe we
don't know all of them.
What are their rituals?
What currently works at
conferences and where there
might be friction points?
Where are there opportunities
where we can fix friction
points with our app?
So how would we go about this?
So at Android, we're happy to
have Helena and her User
Experience Research Team, which
we already talked about
when we introduced the team.
They're sort of what you would
call expert gatherers,
analyzers, interpreters, and
distributors of information.
They will actually go out to
conference, interview people,
observe people.
Maybe shadow them for a while
to see what they're really
doing, how they interact with
other conference goers, what
is important to them, what
is not important to them.
And actually what Helena
probably will do is she will
most likely ask to designer, the
engineer and the product
manager that works on
that particular
project, to come along.
Case in point, here's a picture
of a user study that
we did a while ago where we
visited actual users to find
out how phones and tablets,
other electronic devices, sort
of fit into their daily lives.
The interesting thing here is
that this guy in the picture
is actually a software
engineer.
So he essentially changed his
job description for the few
weeks and helped gather
information on how users
interact with devices.
And he did that particularly
on things that he would be
coding a few weeks after.
So he really had the user's
perspective of what was
important, what was
not important.
So if you do that, if you have
a team and you do information
collection, do bring product
managers and software
developers along.
Because it really helps to focus
your entire team on user
wants and needs.
If on the other hand you're the
app army of one that we
already talked about, gathering
information is still possible.
And it will pay off
handsomely.
And anybody can really do it.
So for the price basically of a
coffee at Starbucks, you'll
find people that will just love
to sit down with you and
talk a little bit about what
they like and don't like about
an app or a particular
electronic device.
If you do the information
collection, let's say for
example you do a note-taking
app.
If you do a note-taking app, it
really pays off to go out
to a couple of users, 10, 20,
maybe, and ask them, how do
you manage notes in real life?
And sort of latch.
Learn more about that.
And have your app really latch
onto those processes.
Bottom line is that it's a good
idea to make information
gathering an integral part
of your workflow.
And in the end, you'll be glad
you did because it also will
serve your development time
because you have a much better
initial quality of
your product.
So back to our example here.
So now Helena and I, who went to
the conference, do a little
bit of research.
We came back and we brought home
a bunch of interesting
things to look at, such as
printed materials, the
proceedings, and maps, and
whatever you get when you sign
into a conference.
Then we would do some
interviews, possibly some
questionnaires.
And then we would take pictures,
make observations,
and see what people are
actually doing at a
conference.
All this material, so it can
help you to get context and
get a better understanding
of what
conference goers needs are.
So when we come back, we would
take all that information,
probably lock ourselves into
a room for a while.
And then analyze, see what we
got up and see where the
morsels are that we can
use for our apps.
So let's look at some
other things in
detail, such as here.
The schedule master plan.
Everybody has probably
seen one.
So this gives you
an at a glance
overview of the sessions.
And Helena actually also here
brought back a copy of a
schedule that a conference
goer has marked up.
So the fact that they carry it
with them at all times and
refer to it often already
tells us that this is an
important item.
So this is an individualized
item.
Then we brought back a map.
Which is, of course, helpful to
find your way around at a
conference, find restrooms,
exhibitions.
And of course the session rooms
of the talks that you're
interested in.
And I made an observation here
that sort of puts the maps in
context with the schedule
because users try
to keep them close.
So those little clues can be
really important if you
construct an app.
Next up, the detailed
daily schedule.
This is basically, it gives
you more the detailed
information about a
particular talk.
Who's speaking.
What it's about.
And Helena here explains how the
session details really fit
into the user's workflow for
establishing a personal schedule.
People at conferences need
to share information.
Of course, communication sharing
won't quite look like
this on an electronic device,
but we can basically register
the user need.
People like to talk to
each other, exchange
information, share.
So that is something that
we want to support
in the app as well.
And then the questionnaire here
crystallizes our social
and organizational goal.
Another good clue for supporting
some sort of
sharing in our app to allow
people to tell other people
what sessions they're
going to.
Now interviews and general
observations are great because
they basically allow you to make
accidental discoveries.
Things you maybe you haven't
even planned for.
Sometimes you think, well,
we're going to collect
information about this
topic and that topic.
But if you talk to people, if
you observe them, you make
those really nice accidental
observations.
And in this case, it seems like
users need a helping hand
to be reminded of some of the
schedules and stay organized.
So with all of that information
in hand, we're
pretty well-equipped to sort
of formulate the tactical
goals that serve our
app's purpose.
Since our research uncovered a
lot of communication sharing
topics, we're sort of extending
the goal a little
bit to say a socially connected
conference guide.
So that is now part of
our elevator speech.
To organize the goals a little
bit, we divide them up into
different buckets-- before,
during, and after.
Before is mostly
planning goals.
Some of those goals will carry
over into the during phase.
But the during phase is mostly
about personal organization
and communication.
We want to always also service
the after-conference aspect a
little bit by allowing you to
see a session recap so that
you don't have to bring home
the fat proceedings.
And also sort of share what you
felt I/O was like for you.
But clearly the need for a
conference guide is the before
and during phase.
So in our airport analogy we
said that a building's purpose
drives the user's expectation
of functional places.
And translated to our app, that
really means that our
app's purpose as a conference
guide shapes a user's
expectation of certain familiar
things to be available.
And we just collected some of
those familiar things that
people will like to see in an
app and feel familiar when
they see it.
So let's see how the real world
artifacts we collected
match up to our goals.
So the schedule master plan,
that's the individual plan.
Conference, explore the program,
find interesting
sessions, and stay organized.
So all of those organizational
things.
The map allows me to find my
way around the conference.
The session details let
me read about the
detail of the sessions.
And the bulletin board is sort
of the collection item, if you
so want, for all the
communication needs that
people have at conferences.
So we said that real life
objects can be indicative of
expected places for users.
And those objects that we just
talked about, they have proven
valuable many times over
at conferences.
And reusing them in some shape
or form in our app will make
users feel like they're looking
at something familiar.
But how should those
important places be
represented on an app?
How should the UI for the
bulletin board, for example,
look like on an app?
Would that be the best idea?
If you think about it, physical
objects were really
designed for the physical world
and therefore play by
slightly different rules than
objects on your phone.
Applying real world object to
the virtual world can give you
a lot of headaches if you're
approaching it too literally.
Simply doing a one-on-one port
of our bulletin board UI to
the phone where the only things
you can do is sort of
add and remove little snippets
of information within a
restrictive place, would
obviously simply
not be a good idea.
Because the content is hard
to scan on the phone.
You probably would have to zoom
in and out all the time.
You never know when new stuff,
for example, pops up.
You have a really inflexible,
finite layout.
And you probably-- because of
that-- you probably have
multiple layers and content
might overlap.
So doing a literal translation
here would simply not work.
So you should really spend some
time if you have those
real life artifacts that you've
collected in the real
world and translate them
into the virtual world.
Think about, of course, for
example, how you want your
objects to be recognizable
but you want them to be
supercharged versions of
the real life objects.
Let's look at some examples of
how you can convert real life
objects to virtual ones for
the purpose of our app.
So for example, if you look at
the schedule master plan that
already visited, visitors mainly
use it for exploring
what sessions are available.
So sort of a mini database
for the conference.
But they also use it for
establishing a personal schedule.
The personal schedule out of the
multitude of events, that
is very similar to what the
agenda is doing on the phone
or in the Android calendar,
for example.
You're going to have an at a
glance view of your day.
You can add and remove things.
So that sounds really a
model that works for a
personalized schedule.
Then translating the master
schedule to an agenda and a
separate program object really
matches well with our goals.
It allows us to have a
personalized schedule and to
program of the database that
we want to access while we
search for things by time, by
place, or by [? trek. ?]
Then the conference map, of
course, has a strong analogy
to something like the Google
Maps app on Android.
So we basically know what
the interactions
here should look like.
So you can pinch to zoom.
You can explore the content in
certain significant places by
clicking on the pins
and so forth.
And since we already have an
agenda and sort of a session
browse object, the only thing
that we're missing is a place
where users can learn
about the details.
So that is sort of the same
as the details schedule.
So this is also a good place
to address two of our
remaining goals, that is of
sharing and viewing the
session recap.
So that's also useful object.
Of course for communication
the modern analogy of a
bulletin board is sort of a
feed or stream where users
that know about the name
of a feed can post to
it, replied to it.
You can get to know people that
way, add them to your
phone book and so forth.
So now that we have all those
objects defined and we know
that they're going to be useful
in some shape or form,
it makes sense to get an
overview of what the
functional relationships
between those are.
So what you can do is you can,
for example, write down the
objects that you collected, that
you transferred into the
virtual world.
And--
oops.
There we go.
And add what the content of
those objects will be like.
For example, agenda here
consists of a timeline--
sessions and other events.
So that already gives you an
approximation of what the
content of that screen
will be.
Second off, you can
add actions.
And these are now actions that
you can invoke on the object
but that don't take you
away from the object.
And as a third step, you can
add a navigation path.
So basically functions that take
you from one object to
another object and the name of
the function that basically
collects the two.
So this can be a really useful
exercise for you to sort of
get a first overview at how
complex your app is going to
be and how everything
hangs together.
So now let's get to
the next step.
We spent about half an hour
of the talk already.
And I haven't drawn
a single screen.
And that goes to show that the
design, the foundation of the
design often isn't about
drawing screens.
It's about collecting
information.
But now we're at a point
where we want to start
drawing some screens.
And with that, I hand
it over to Rachel.
RACHEL GARB: Thanks, Jens.
OK.
So let's design some screens.
We usually recommend starting
with the top level screen.
Now why?
It's where users' first
impressions are formed.
It orients users to what
the app can do and
how they get around.
And in many apps it's going to
be the place where users spend
the most time.
So this really is a make
or break screen.
So let's continue to use the
I/O app as an example, and
we'll take a stab at designing
the top level screen.
I want to start by pondering
this question.
What should be the hero
of the screen?
And what I mean by that, what
will help users accomplish
their most important tasks in
the shortest amount of time?
What will make them conquer
the challenges
of attending I/O?
What will save the day?
If you're not into the hero
analogy, there are other ways
to phrase this question.
Want to throw out some ideas?
NATE STREU: Top dog.
JENS NAGEL: The big cheese.
RACHEL GARB: Yeah.
Cool.
So all of the research and
thinking that Jens walked us
through so far is going
to help us figure out
what the hero is.
Now as we learned, normally at
conferences like this people
get a program and they go
through it page by page and
they circle things that
look interesting.
And then if they get a master
schedule, they then transfer
those circles to the master
schedule and they carry it
with them wherever they go.
So that's pretty powerful
right there.
This is their personal agenda.
And it aids them in planning and
attending the conference.
It's very time-critical
information and it needs to be
at the surface.
So let's make the agenda the
hero of our top level screen.
Now let's sketch out very
roughly how that could look on
a phone and a tablet.
I like to start with
the action bar.
It's already in place
there, as you see.
Let's put in some branding.
And plan for an action
overflow.
This is a place where we can
have a menu for secondary
actions that are not used so
often, like settings and help.
And, of course, our
hero-- tada--
the agenda.
But at the beginning, the agenda
will be mostly empty.
So it's important that our top
level screen also provides a
way for users to find things
to fill up the agenda.
There are two key ways
that conference
goers approach this.
First, they would start with a
track like Android and see
what sessions are available.
And then pick a few that
are interesting to
add to their agenda.
Another way that they would do
it is to choose a time slot,
see what sessions are available,
and pick one.
Let's make sure that our top
level screen supports both.
On a tablet, we have room to
add a menu of the various
tracks in a second column.
On the phone, we don't
have that luxury.
So let's have tabs.
We can have one for the
agenda and another
for the tracks menu.
Now when you are using tabs,
it's important that you think
of them as being the same
part of one screen.
That's not two screens.
It's one.
So this is all still part of our
top level screen as far as
we're concerned.
Now users can touch the track
that they want to get a list
of sessions.
And, of course we know that
users also like to touch a
time slot to get a list
of offerings.
So let's offer that too.
Now if that's all we offer in
the top level screen, it'd be
way better than the old
paper method, right?
But we can do even better.
After all, this is an
interactive conference program.
So let's add some things here.
How about search?
We could let users search the
program for a particular
keyword in sessions.
This seems important enough
to put in the top level.
Or in the action bar of
the top level menu.
We could also give them one
touch access to a map of the
conference screen.
One way we could do that is to
have another button in the
action bar.
Or another way we could do it
is to have a button in the
explore menu, which is what
you see in the final app.
And since conference have become
popular venues for
heavy social networking
activity, why don't we give
that some prominence on the
top level screen too?
Now I could go on, but I
think you get the idea.
You start with the most basic
goal and place the objects and
actions that relate to it.
Next you figure out what other
objects and actions might be
nice to have on the screen.
Or at least accessible
from it.
And you work those in too.
OK.
Next, let's talk a little bit
about lower level screens.
They serve various purposes.
And here are a few examples
of the role that they can
play in your app.
One thing they can let you do
is drill deeper into data.
For example, browsing a photo
album in the gallery.
Another thing they can't let you
do is edit data, like when
you're composing a
message in Gmail.
And another thing they can let
you do is consume data.
For example, reading a book.
Let's work on a lower level
screen in the I/O app.
In this case, let's work on the
screen that appears when
you touch a time slot.
This is an example of drilling
deeper into data.
So I like to start by giving the
screen a title so that it
conveys a purpose and
a sense of place.
The user is going to get here
by touching a time slot in
main level or the top level
screen and then arrive here
and expect to see a
list of sessions.
So it kind of makes sense that
the date and time would be a
good title.
But it's not just a time slot.
It's a time slot at the
I/O conference.
Carry your brand name
throughout your app.
It's another way that you can
establish a sense of place.
Now did you notice that we're
using a smaller logo here than
we did on the top
level screen?
We're doing that because we
have a longer label and we
have other actions that
we're eventually
going to want to place.
This will give us more
room for that.
Next, let's bring in the hero
of the screen, which is the
list of sessions in
the time slot.
Users will be able to touch one
to get session details.
Now you can imagine that users
will probably alternate a lot
between viewing the list
of sessions and
reading session details.
I call this pogo sticking.
And on the tablet, because we
have more space, we may be
able to cut down on that
pogo sticking.
So let's see if we can make use
of the space by having two
panes where the user selects a
time slot on the left and sees
details on the right.
In the actual app, Roman did a
twist on the two pane layout
where you see a portion of the
details pane just kind of
peeking out until you
select a session.
And then the details
takes over.
Now either of these approaches
are great for combining two
levels of hierarchy on
larger screen sizes.
But the phone doesn't have space
for a second column.
So we'll eventually need to
design a separate screen for
session details.
So at this point, the tablet
lets users see what sessions
are available and
details for the
currently selected session.
But we also need to let them add
a session to their agenda.
So let's add a way to do
that on the tablet.
One way we could do it is to
have a button as part of the
session info.
Another way we could do it would
be to have an icon in
the action bar, like you
see in the actual app.
So now the screen fulfills
its entire goal.
But there's one more important
thing left to do.
Because this is a lower level
screen, include an up arrow.
It's the standard way in Android
to enable navigating
up the hierarchy.
Now this is different than
the system back key.
That's for historical
navigation.
As Matias mentioned, a few of
our colleagues will be digging
deeper into the topic of
navigation and Android in this
room today at 11:30, and
we hope you'll attend.
OK.
Now the screen fulfills
its goal.
It uses a standard convention
for navigating up.
The next step is to decide if
we want anything else, to
offer any other objects or
actions on the screen.
For example, it would be nice
to bring up a map to the
location of your session or
share details of the session
with your favorite network.
So that's an example of
a lower level screen.
And you can repeat this process
for all the screens in
your app to build up your
full set of sketches.
Now the sketches you just saw,
which we call wire frames,
they didn't require any special
artistic ability or
design training to create.
It's really all about drawing
shapes and text and arranging
them into defined areas.
And you don't need any
specialized tools.
The Android designers
all have different
ways of wire framing.
I use a tool called OmniGraffle
for the Mac.
And Jens uses Adobe
Illustrator.
And other folks on the team
prefer paper and pencil, like
Nate over here.
NATE STREU: All right.
That's a lot of stuff.
And great, great information.
So what's the next thing
we can do here?
And I think one of those things
is bringing these wire
frames to life.
And one of the easiest ways to
get started, whether you're
one of those app army of one or
you're a dedicated visual
designer on a larger team, is
to spend time on the Android
design site because it's rich
in tools that help you get
started and will continue to
update as we go along.
Rachel mentioned earlier one
of the most important
resources to be considering is
the building blocks section.
And as we mentioned, it's made
up of Android's ready to use
system and framework elements
like tabs or
buttons or text fields.
And I can't stress enough the
importance of getting familiar
with these pieces as you
begin to craft your
scenes in higher fidelity.
Fortunately, we've made it a
little easier to them to
practical use when applying
visual designs.
The Android design site now
has downloadable building
block stencils and source files
for a variety of common
different software
applications.
And the stencils will allow you
to quickly visualize your
app using real Android UI.
And I'm going to go
into a little
detail about that later.
The great thing is these things
are vector-based.
So it's easy to scale for
multiple resolutions or
customize things like colors and
fonts should you choose.
And anyone with a working
knowledge of Photoshop or
Illustrator or Fireworks will
find it a breeze to put these
stencils to good use.
I also want to note that the
download section also includes
common system icons, color
swatches, and stunning Roboto
typeface that's used
throughout Android.
I'd recommend you download
all of these tools.
So next up, you're going to want
to target some specific
form factors for your hero
screen visual designs.
As you all know, Android powers
millions of phones and
tablets, many with different
screen sizes and resolutions.
And you'll want to support
as many of
those as you have time.
And Rachael showed us how she
kept the phone and tablet
layouts in mind when
constructing the wire frames.
You'll need to do the same when
applying visual design.
And don't forget about
orientation.
You want to make sure your
designs support both landscape
and portrait.
But for the purpose of this
demo, let's keep it simple.
We'll pick one.
We'll go with the Galaxy Nexus
in a portrait orientation.
OK.
So at this point it's really
valuable to identify the key
screens and components that
you're going to need to mock
up in visual design.
And while complex wire frames
may include a lot of screens,
it's usually not necessary to
create pixel perfects for
every version.
You want to pick the hero
screens that showcase the
app's core functionality.
Usually it's a mix of top level
and lower level screens
in a variety of different
resolutions and orientations.
So for our purposes, let's
focus on the top
level agenda view.
Now here's a quick look at the
Photoshop stencils that are
available on the download.
You should notice that they're
available for both
light and dark UIs.
And this is done to support
system theming.
And themes are Android's way
of applying a consistent
visual style across an
app or activity.
Getting comfortable with these
themes will go a long way in
helping you build apps that
complement the general visual
language of Android.
So you can choose from three
system themes when you're
starting to build your apps.
Holo light, as you can see
here, leveraged in Gmail.
And a variation, Holo light
with dark action bars.
That's shown here in Talk.
This is really good for when you
want a little more visual
differentiation between
the action bar
and the page content.
And here's Holo dark,
which you can see in
the settings screen.
So you want to make sure you
choose a theme that matches
the needs and design aesthetics
you're looking for.
It's also worth mentioning
that if you want a more
distinct look, using one of
these themes as a starting
point for personal customization
is a great idea.
In the case of the I/O app,
however, let's use the Holo
light variation with the
dark action bar.
So we've identified
a key screen.
We've picked a theme.
Let's start laying out some of
the core building blocks of
the I/O app.
I'm going to refer to Rachel's
wire frames as a guide to the
objects and actions that should
be included here.
So I'm going to start with
mocking our hero agenda by
using the building blocks
from the stencil kit.
I'm going to start with a blank
canvas, which happens to
be the default Holo
light background.
And next I'm going to add some
global system elements that
frame your app such as
the status bar and
the navigation bar.
And next, as Rachel mentioned,
the action bar is a huge part
of the Android UI.
So let's add that to our canvas
from our stencil kit.
So you want to notice that the
stencil kit comes pre-loaded
with the up indicator as well
as the action overflow.
And these are very, very useful
since most of Android's
UI will leverage these
functions.
And now with the action bar in
place, we've gotten not only
the most important structural
element to your app, but also
a great opportunity, as Rachel
mentioned, to brand
or title your page.
So let's do that by adding
the I/O launcher
icon and page title.
Because this is a top level
screen, I've removed the up
icon used in the lower
level screens.
And while we're here, I want
to pay special attention to
talk a little more about the
importance of the launcher
icon within your app.
So the launcher icon is usually
the first impression
the user will have with
your product.
So it's important to have the
character of this icon reflect
the brand or the character that
you're hoping to achieve.
It's used all over the place.
It's used in the Play Store,
it's used on Android's
customizable home screen, and
also within your app.
So it's really, really important
that your icon is
clearly legible on all
types of backgrounds.
You're also going to want to
keep the metaphors simple when
doing your launcher icon.
Overly complex icons look
great on really high
resolution, but they can really
scale poorly, resulting
in a loss of detail
and clarity.
And not everybody is a visual
designer or a pixel
perfectionist.
But a lot of users are going
to notice a poorly executed
launcher icon.
And when they do, chances are
they think your app is too.
So really pay attention
to this one.
So next we're going to address
the most important actions
people take.
And we saw this in Rachel's
wire frames.
In this case, we're going to add
search and refresh to the
action bar in addition
to the overflow menu.
If there's not enough room, as
Rachel mentioned earlier,
additional actions could also be
surfaced in a split action
bar or within that
action overflow.
So as I mentioned earlier, the
design site provides downloads
for the common pre-defined icons
that you can use to mock
up your UIs in both Holo light
and Holo dark themes.
And it also includes some handy
implementation notes.
We highly recommend you take
advantage of these.
It's not only less work for you
guys, but it's also going
to have better continuity
with the system.
And if these pre-canned icons
don't meet your needs, the
design guide also has detailed
specs for creating your own
under iconography in
the style section.
All right.
So back to our I/O app.
Next I'm going to throw in some
tabs from the stencils
for navigation between
our top level views.
And because the agenda view is
really, really similar to a
standard framework list
view, we'll grab
that from the stencil.
In this case, I'm using a
two-line Holo light list.
Note that the templates also
include common list elements
such as section dividers--
which will be perfect
for breaking our
agenda up into days--
list action icons, and default
contact avatars.
So for our purposes, I'm going
to remove the last couple of
bits, though that avatar could
come handy if we were mocking
up the social stream.
And like that, in a few quick
steps you can bring your
sketches and wire
frames to life.
It's really that easy.
And by following our design
guide and using the resource
we've put at your fingertips,
you can quickly visualize a UI
that not only meets its
functional purposes, but also
begins to approach
app Nirvana.
So why stop here?
Let's look at some of the ways
customizing the building
blocks can apply to our I/O app
and help take it to that
next level.
Great place to start with
the actual bar again.
So I've gone a little
darker and applied a
subtle pattern to it.
And I've also injected a little
color what the tabs.
You'll notice a difference the
addition of color adds to the
dynamic of the page and visual
hierarchy in the objects on
the screen.
The action bar recedes while
the top level tabs come
forward, giving you a clear
indication of where you are
and where you can go.
It also reinforces the
brand color used in
our launcher icon.
So it would also help if our
agenda view not only had a
daily breakdown, but an
hourly break down.
So using the stencil kit and
referencing the metrics and
grid section of the design
guide, it's simple to
visualize this customization
of a standard list view.
And there we have it.
Something that resembles very,
very closely what the final
product looked like.
So with just a few small
tweaks to our stencils,
referencing our wire frames,
we've succeeded in quickly
visualizing a functional and
differentiated app experience
very, very simply.
It's also super easy to
visualize alternate approaches
by using these building
blocks.
When doing custom work, pay
special attention to type and
iconography contrast
when you're
adjusting these UI elements.
It's really important
that these
things are still legible.
Now hopefully most of you guys
are staying in the room for
the next talk, which Matias
alluded to earlier called So
You've Read the Design
Guide, Now What?
This session is going to dive
a little deeper into some of
the things we discussed today
and give you more practical
strategies for applying fit
and finish to your app.
We highly recommend
you check it out.
And with that, I'm going to hand
it back over to Rachel.
RACHEL GARB: OK.
So we're at the end
of our talk now.
And if there's one message that
we want you to take away
today, it's this.
When it comes to creating
Android apps,
design is always doable.
So the key is to start at the
bottom of the pyramid and work
your way up.
Your target users, your purpose,
and the Android
design guide will help
you along the way.
Good luck and thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL GARB: And now we'd like
to invite Matias and Roman to
come up on the stage
and help us answer
some of your questions.
MATIAS DUARTE: Come on
out in front, guys.
RACHEL GARB: Yep.
MATIAS DUARTE: Thank
you, thank you.
So we have a few minutes
for a few questions.
We've got some mics in the
center if folks want to ask.
Or you could raise your hand.
Or we could just stand
here and look pretty.
One question in the front.
AUDIENCE: Do you guys have a
download pack [INAUDIBLE]?
I don't know if it's changed
yet, but all of the
[INAUDIBLE].
MATIAS DUARTE: Oh,
the asset names.
OK, so the question was about
the naming of the assets in
the download pack of icons.
And what's the answer to that?
NATE STREU: The answer should
be that we will update those
so it's easier for
you to do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NATE STREU: We'll
see about that.
[LAUGHTER]
MATIAS DUARTE: OK, thank you.
Yes?
Next question.
AUDIENCE: When can we expect to
see anything on the design
site fly in menu?
MATIAS DUARTE: Oh,
fly in menu.
You mean the pattern that you
see in the Google+ app?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE].
MATIAS DUARTE: Well, just like
our products we don't like to
pre-announce anything
for the style guide.
But, yes.
Just for you I will answer that
we are working on updates
for the style guide for
that pattern as well.
[APPLAUSE]
MATIAS DUARTE: All right.
NATE STREU: We got a--
MATIAS DUARTE: Oh, OK.
Audience question.
AUDIENCE: Most of the times as
developers, we try to follow
the design guidelines
that you've given.
But when we are working for
somebody else and a customer
asks us to create rich
application.
And when we show this design
guideline, they say, we want
to follow another device and
we want to mimic the same
experience on both devices.
So how to answer that?
MATIAS DUARTE: Right.
So that's an excellent
question.
As a brand or as a company you
want to build a consistent
identity across all the
platforms that you build on.
But at the same time, you want
users to be delighted and
successful in the platform
that they're on.
We actually have a specific
section in design guide that
shows how to translate some
of those elements.
And so if you're dealing with
a customer or a manager who
doesn't understand that, that's
a good place to start.
The biggest principle to keep
in mind is the design
guide is just that.
It's a guide.
It's actually intended to be
very flexible with regards to
your branding.
In fact, I'd invite you to
come to the Playing with
Patterns session at the end
of the day to see very
practically how people adapt
the design guideline while
still maintain the integrity
of their own app.
The reason why you want to
follow the design guide for
all of the important principles
is that you may
feel really good about having
consistency across all these
different platforms,
but a user is
only using one platform.
Maybe two.
The desktop and their device.
And the desktop experience and
their device are going to be
completely different.
If the experience on the device
is different than what
they expect, they're actually
going to have a worse time.
That's a competitive
disadvantage.
If you have a competitor that
is actually hewing closer to
the design guide in terms of
metrics, contrast, even simple
expected things like are our
tabs at the top or the bottom,
your competitor all of a sudden
has an advantage.
And that's really the key
point I would stress.
AUDIENCE: And one
more question.
MATIAS DUARTE: OK.
AUDIENCE: With few of the
latest apps, you started
introducing navigation elements
on the bottom.
That never used to be a
standard in earlier--
like now you have a search bar
and you have more navigation
elements right above the--
MATIAS DUARTE: With Ice Cream
Sandwich we introduced the
split action bar that allows
you to put actions from the
action bar at the bottom of the
screen to basically enable
us to do things like small phone
layouts where you still
want to have a lot of contextual
header information
at the top, still have important
actions at your
fingertips, without creating
this layer cake stack at the
top of your app.
That's not actually used
for navigations.
Those are really used for
actions themselves.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
MATIAS DUARTE: Sure.
All right, we've got
a line here.
So let's see how many of them
we can get through.
AUDIENCE: Based on the look and
feel of the UI elements of
these design guidelines, it
appears to me that these are
specifically for native apps.
How do these design guidelines
apply to mobile web apps and
hybrid apps?
MATIAS DUARTE: Well, they are
the Android design guidelines.
Do you want talk to?
NATE STREU: Go ahead.
MATIAS DUARTE: OK.
I'll take it.
All right.
I'm taking this one.
So I think web apps obviously
have the incredible power of
being deployed on multiple
platforms.
But just like any app that is
trying to be deployed on
multiple platforms, it wants
to be quite as native as
possible for the exact same
reason of the last question.
I think those you have to be
a little bit more careful.
But things like using basic
metrics and using enough of
the contrast and typography
conventions are going to make
your web apps fit into
the rest of the
Android native app world.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATIAS DUARTE: All right.
It looks like we have time for
one last question and then
we'll sign off.
AUDIENCE: That's me, probably.
MATIAS DUARTE: That's you.
Go ahead.
I don't see any other hands.
AUDIENCE: My question for you,
how much time do you spend on
the design part?
What's the ratio between
design and development?
And at what time did Roman came
in doing the development?
MATIAS DUARTE: I feel like I
need to have other people
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: So the funny thing
about Google I/O is that
it's a three-day conference.
So you can't really spend
a long, long, long time
designing and developing
something for a three-day
conference.
So actually, the design
and development took
about two or so months.
And it was an integrated
effort.
A lot of people were involved.
So it wasn't really designed
and then developed.
It was really an iteration cycle
over about a few months.
MATIAS DUARTE: I'd like
to say one last
thing to close on that.
First off, that's a great
example about how design is
always doable, even
if you have a
very, very short timeline.
And also a great example about
how using the standard Android
framework elements and the
design guide can make your app
development much faster.
Because you're not reinventing
the wheel.
But the other point that Roman
made is also critical.
Design and development is
not a waterfall process.
It's iterative.
You want to get broad
strokes sketched in.
Think of design like progressive
JPEG decoding.
You want get the light and the
dark parts really blurry
first, make sure you're not
making any critical mistakes,
and then keep refining
quickly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MATIAS DUARTE: I think we're
cutting you off.
[LAUGHTER]
MATIAS DUARTE: Come join
us for drinks later.
All right, well thank you
very much everybody.
And thank you to
the presenters.
[APPLAUSE]